my dad really changed his tuneup this
year I'll tell you that much did yeah
but you do you blame him
yes yes for sure I know there's always
that little thing where it's it's like
you want to tell like my parents are
immigrants yeah so you know I I wanted
to sit down and go remember the 10 years
you're like you're never going to make
you know you're not good you know what I
mean right like every day go to colge
you know and now now look right and then
but you know they change they're like oh
you know congratulations I'm so proud of
you you know what I mean and you can't
just go what the [__] but deep down
inside it's there still a little bit
yeah but you're dealing with way more I
don't mean to again be Dr stavos here
but you have you you're one of the most
abused children of all time your dad
[__] your [__] up bro I see the clips
I see the
[__] like my dad was kind of rude to
me you know yeah I guess you're right he
didn't beat me with [__] golf clubes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
tennis rackets and stuff yeah yeah yeah
exactly I did write a new joke there it
didn't work and I just tell see what the
joke is sure and maybe it's not funny
are we workshopping no I just I thought
it would be funny but maybe it needs
more right so basically my dad used to
beat me with golf clubs right and I go
and that's why I hate golf today like I
can't watch I [__] hate it right if
on TV he used to beat me with tennis
rackets and if I see a tennis racket I
get PTSD trauma so then I'm so glad my
didn't dad didn't beat me with
[__] the structure is good [__] makes
no sense though why because I love [__]
and I what if I if you put me with [__]
I would hate it now yeah yeah yeah that
connection it took a while for my brain
to get there yeah yeah yeah it's so
stupid I would do something other than
[__] but I like we like two things I
hate I tried to do a formula thing right
what a pizza then I'm so glad my dad
didn't beat me with Pizza H still I
can't connect it in my yeah how why
can't you connect it I I connected it
and then you connected it um yeah yeah
but it didn't elicit
uh because it's not because it's not
funny it's not a joke that works no but
the beginning though the the the setup
was really funny yeah so yeah so glad
didn't yeah yeah yeah yeah no no yeah
cuz those are that that is a good setup
and it is you know you understand where
I'm going I just can't cuz I tried it on
stage night and it just got nothing I go
[__] yeah yeah well you're also
expecting it too much probably yeah but
no you got nothing yeah yeah
oh [__] that doesn't work yeah do you
ever do that when you try a new joke you
think it's going to Works those are the
ones that always fa fail the ones that
you're sure you got a banger and you're
like they're going to [__] car me out
to this one and then it's like crickets
and then you accidentally [__] up a joke
and that's the way it's now is yeah you
know what I mean they just laugh at that
you're like I I didn't write it that way
but I [__] it up but I guess that's
how I'm going to keep it yeah it's nice
to just go up there loose and see what
the [__] happens but I like that is that
what you do I do yeah you know you never
go I'm going to say this this and this
and these new things I have them as
bullet points and that the first couple
times I just like however they come out
they come out and then I go back try and
get the wording right after I've said it
like four or five times but do you know
where the funny is I think so because
sometimes I'll go you know I have a
premise I don't even know where it's
funny yeah that happens a lot too yeah
I'm like I'm going to just try and then
you just give it a shot but then you'll
start talking about it and you're like
uhoh there's nothing here well it's like
you know yeah but it's like those videos
where they just throw a baby in a pool
and it just kind of figures out what the
[__] to do all right that's what you got
to do s or Swim sink or swim yeah yeah
yeah and you know I'm good at too is
bailing yeah you ever bail I I like yeah
I mean I've bailed before yeah yeah I
love bailing you just doesn't feel good
no what you do is you're saying a new
joke premise right and you and you don't
really know where the punch line is and
you're halfway there and then you
realize oh [__] there's no out but then
you figure out an older joke that you
can segue into
so I've done that before Oh a seamless
bail yeah like I thought you were going
to do like a bail that's like that's not
going to [__] work I've done that too
and yeah that you guys saw me right
through that that was a new joke all
right yeah I've done that yeah that's
it's so embarrassing though you get one
of those per set you can't do it twice
you can't you can't be like you still
have bad shows sure really I mean if I'm
you know new stuff yeah it's tough it is
I'm sure you feel this way too where
it's like when people are coming to see
you it's almost like it doesn't it
doesn't feel as fun you know what I mean
like I miss having to win over a crowd
that despises you has no idea who the
[__] you are you had to be sharper
although I say that and then I bet if I
saw tapes of me doing comedy I was
probably so bad at it but there is
something to it sometimes it feels too
easy and you have to kind of hold
yourself accountable and do shittier
shows or do unannounced shows so that
not everyone's your fan because
everybody's your fan it's just you know
see that show I did in the belly room
was the same thing they didn't knew I
was on when they called me up I fig felt
like they didn't know who I was and it
became hard and that's how I was pissed
off about that wa they didn't know who
you were I yeah that's what I felt at
the belly room yeah it wasn't I wasn't
advertised it was like some random
promoter if it's a small enough show
you'll be surprised I'm not that famous
you are pretty famous dude but you're
famous too then you're more famous than
me I don't think so I think you are I
don't think I could sell the tickets you
sell I don't know who knows about that
stavie can I say something yeah sure you
have the nicest skin I have ever scene
thanks yeah it's my f it's my good
attribute that